we have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2, David P..
Yesterday we talked about when it comes to
people who hear Trump talk about injecting
bleach and they go and they ingest bleach,
should we care about that?
Is it a Darwinian thinning of the herd?
Should we not care about the plight of the
cond?
Here's a voicemail about exactly that issue,
David.
Jeff in Oregon, hey, I heard you say suggesting
that we should absolve Trump's followers,
Luke, but major issues.
There is no crime in those sectors.
There is no poor leader without followers.
Certainly Republican politicians who know
better should be held criminally culpable,
but his followers need to be programed and
must look in the mirror and see what they've
caused.
Listen, I am not trying to absolve people
who go and inject bleach of any responsibility,
but the caller says they need to be deprogrammed.
Well, that means that they've been programed
to begin with and they didn't program themselves.
So I think that there's plenty of blame to
go around.
We have an education system that is failing
people.
We have a political system that is failing
We have an economic system that is failing
people.
I'm not looking to absolve anybody of the
actions that they choose to take.
And if personal responsibility.
But I do stop short of saying, hey, let's
absolve the con men.
Of any responsibility and simply criticized
those who have been caught.
That doesn't seem right to me either.
We've got a terrific bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it.
Become a member or patron today to get instant
access.
I'll talk to you then or otherwise tomorrow.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.